à travers le rapport que nous avons fait
à travers près de 45 auditions à travers
le questionnaire qui a battu des records
sur le site du Sénat nous voyons très
bien que ces mesures ne sont pas
acceptées ou en tout cas pas bien
comprises par nos concitoyens je
rappelle que dans certains pays
européens le calendrier de ZFE et sur
une vingtaine d'années en France il est
sur 5 ans donc on s'aperçoit que les
habitants aiment sont pas informés et
dont leur demande très rapidement de se
débarrasser de véhicules qui pour eux
ont une valeur vénale une valeur
sentimentale et également représente
quelques fois le seul moyen pour aller
travailler
il faut aider à travers des bonus qui
existent aujourd'hui mais notamment les
ménages les plus modestes ceux qui
habitent hors des ZFE qui n'ont pas de
solution de transport en commun
disponible et puis aussi favoriser le
report modal à travers un choc de
l'offre en transport qui doivent venir
dans notre pays et qui fait défaut
aujourd'hui il est aussi important de
pouvoir aider les personnes qui
souhaitent changer de véhicule et pas
forcément en passant à l'électrique mais
sur des voitures
plus récentes et sans sous diesel et qui
rentre encore dans les normes c'est une
étape qu'on a proposé puisqu'on propose
le bonus écologique une chose est sûre
c'est qu'on ne peut pas si on ne bouge
pas le calendrier interdire à 13
millions de Français de prendre à court
terme leur voiture donc nous devons agir
j'espère que le gouvernement prendra en
compte nos recommandations nos neuf
recommandations qui vont dans le bon
sens qui sont raisonnables et qui
pourraient permettre de desserrer
véritablement cet étau il y a une
possibilité aussi quand vous avez des
personnes qui entretiennent
particulièrement bien leur véhicule même
s'il n'est plus autorisé à rouler avec
un contrôle déco entretien ou on
contrôlerait notamment les pots
d'échappement de ces véhicules on
pourrait les laisser fonctionner et
déroger aux règles des vignettes
critères puisque ça paraît logique on
nous demande à titre personnel chez nous
de garder de vieux téléviseurs de garder
de vieilles machines à laver et là on
nous demanderait de jeter des voitures
qui continuent à bien fonctionner donc
véritablement je crois qu'il est
indispensable d'individualiser les
choses aussi c'est une des mesures qu'on
a pu proposer dans notre rapport on a
parlé de bombe sociale et c'est très
juste donc prenons un petit peu plus de
temps gardons des objectifs importants
et que l'on comprend mais essayons de
faire accepter ces mesures aux Français
de les informer des enjeux et je ne
doute pas un instant que sous les
réserves que je viens dénoncer il y aura
des avancées dans les années futures
mais surtout pas marche forcée ça le
gouvernement doit l'entendre
[Musique]